the force is strong with this one
star wars the force awakens second
teaser i know i'm way late on this i was
having technical difficulties i wanted
to shoot this a lot sooner and as a
result i'm actually going to make this
really specific because pretty much
anybody who does any kind of series
about these sorts of things has already
picked this thing apart they've picked
the trailer clean in terms of every
single shot every character shown every
moment shown every implication of what
everything could possibly mean and i
don't want to talk about any of that i
want to talk about one moment that is
the exact moment why to me this is the
best teaser for any film in years i'm
not talking about any specific imagery
that was used i'm not talking about
speculation i'm talking about one moment
that made me feel
something i had not felt in a very long
time about star wars or really almost
any form of entertainment at all i had
chills and i'm not using hyperbole i
felt a literal chill
run down the back of my neck and that
happened at the tail end of luke
speaking because luke is speaking the
exact words that were used in return of
the jedi but it is recorded i i know
return of jedi well enough to know this
is not the original audio that he is
saying these words again now
and he says the force is strong is my
family my father has it yes he used
present tense not past tense i don't
care i don't want to talk about that but
he keeps going i have it
my sister has it and then
screen goes black
you have that power too
and in that moment
he felt like he was talking to me
and that sent an absolute chill down my
spine and i had the biggest grin on my
face and then the words came up this
christmas and i'm like
it feels like a christmas present what
you just gave me and that was amazing
and it really is that moment it really
is just a feel it is a feeling and it's
a feeling i didn't get from the first
teaser and the first teaser was fine i
talked about it i've nitpicked it a
little bit since then but first t-server
was solid it was good but it very much
felt like hey look we made more star
wars isn't that awesome i was like yeah
cool looks more like original than it
does uh prequel trilogy so yeah that's
fine but that was the feel of the first
teaser the feel of this teaser thanks to
that moment is
we made more star wars
come and join us
come and celebrate with us come be a
part of this
and that sense of inclusion which it
certainly for a long time fan was
astronomical and maybe even caught on
you know to newer fans or even new
potential fans who aren't that into star
wars in the first place but it just
feels like come with us suddenly just
rang so true to me and just spoke to
the child in me and the unjaded fan in
me because trust me i'm a very jaded
star wars fan but that just cut through
all the cynicism
got straight to the kid in me who grew
up on this and that kid had a friggin
party so what more can i say props to
this trailer props to whoever put it
together whether it was jj abrams or
they got a marketing company i don't
care whoever made this trailer you
deserve the biggest damn bonus at the
end of this year
no joke that's pretty much it for me
what was the part of this trailer that
was your favorite i know for a lot of
people it was seeing han and chewie i
know for some people it was that first
shot with the star destroyer and
tastiest i didn't even realize what it
is i've obviously just gone about what i
think made this trailer epically awesome
so if you liked this trailer what was
the moment you liked best and if you
didn't like this trailer why not
whatever's the case drop something down
in the comments and let's talk about it
until next time this council is
adjourned
you